استغرق الأمر أيامًا حتى يتم إزالة
الحطام من الطرق الجبلية المتعرجة المؤدية إلى الزلزال، مما يجعل من
المستحيل تقريبًا على عمال الإغاثة
الوصول إلى هذه البلدة الصغيرة،
ولكن بعد أسبوع أصبحت مركزًا
للمساعدات الإنسانية بعد
يومين من وقوع الزلزال.
وصل فريق زوهار من الدار البيضاء،
لكنهم لا يعالجون الجروح الجسدية فحسب، بل إن
بعض هؤلاء الأشخاص فقدوا
عائلاتهم بأكملها، يأتي الأطفال ويخبروننا
أن والديهم أو أشقائهم قد
ماتوا،
وأخبرني أحيانًا أن الصدمة العاطفية التي
واجهها هؤلاء الأشخاص أسوأ
من تلك التي واجهها  إن إصاباتهم الجسدية
في هذه المدينة، وبقايا
الحياة المتهالكة قبل الزلزال هي
تذكير دائم بكل ما فقدوه من
منازل وسبل عيش وأحباء
رحلوا في لحظة
عبر جبال المغرب المدمرة،
وهناك قصص لا حصر لها من المأساة التي لم يمسها سوى
القليل من الناس  الموت
وهناك بلدات مثل هذه
تم عزلها لعدة أيام ولكن وسط
قصص الدمار كانت هناك أيضًا
قصص رائعة للبقاء على قيد الحياة.
رئيس الممرضات هنا في
الجحيم هرع إلى سكن القابلات المحلي
مع بصيص من الأمل فقط
ليجد ذلك  كان المبنى قد انهار
وهنا وجد مريم ولا
يزال بإمكانك رؤية وسادتها رأى رأسها
تحت الأنقاض وبدأ يحفر
بنفسه ويسحبها للخارج بمفرده وفي
الظلام يقول إلجين إنه صلى أن تكون الممرضة
ماريون زميلة يعتبرها  لأكون
مثل الأخت التي ستنجو،
توسلت إلي ألا أغادر
وأعدك أنني لن أتركها
بمفردها،
وهي الممرضة مريم التي نجت وهي
مهتزة ومع عدم وجود عيادة
تخبرني أنها أنجبت طفلين يتمتعان بصحة جيدة في
صباح اليوم التالي.
هذه المدينة، مثل كل المتضررين من
الزلزال، لن تنسى أبدا مأساة
8 سبتمبر،
حيث ارتفع عدد القتلى إلى
ما يقرب من 3000 شخص، وبينما
كان هناك تدفق للدعم ليس فقط
من الشعب المغربي ولكن أيضا من
المجتمع الدولي  إن
طريق تعافي هذا البلد
سيكون طويلا
الآن البشير سي إن إن للمخابرات المغربية